uh brian kilmeade a fox news host
on fox and friends says
democrats shouldn't pursue impeachment
against donald trump
which is happening by the way because it
might trigger republicans to do more
violence
this is saying let's negotiate with
terrorists that's what brian kilmeade is
saying here
let's take a look at the video and then
we will discuss
we believe that america could be more
effective and has been ineffective
because we've been at each other's
throats
what could be more disenchanting they
don't want to do that again they don't
want him to run again
they don't want him to run again that's
fine but you don't understand too
there's a lot of people that want him to
number one
continue to be a force in the republican
party believe a lot what he believes
he has 75 million supporters so if you
have an overarching sense that i got to
bring the country together
because we see what's happening around
this country how 50 state houses are
being
threatened on inauguration day this is
the last thing you want to do
it astounds me that now chuck schumer
guys
is exploring a possible work around
using the authority granted to two
senators
back in 2004 to reconvene the senate in
times of emergency
i assume this and have a quick
impeachment vote fantastic idea mitch
mcconnell has to sign off on it
but it would be as dumb as nancy pelosi
hopping on 60 minutes last night
and saying the president's an imminent
threat that's not going to happen
so suddenly the issue is oh there's been
so much political infighting
that is just hilarious but truly
brian kilmeade is saying negotiate
with terrorists the right thing to do is
impeach
but wait the terrorists will get violent
if you do it so don't impeach
only for that reason that's that's not
his phraseology but that's
essentially what he's saying it's the
equivalent of negotiating with
terrorists these are the people
killmead and his cronies on fox who are
always saying you don't negotiate
with terrorists the people they perceive
to be terrorists
if an action is correct if an action is
warranted
you do it you don't let people threaten
you with violence to get you to change
your actions
but because trumpists are likely to get
violent
if you impeach you skip impeachment
what brian what we're hearing from
trumpists
is we will respond with violence
if democrats use a power granted to them
by the constitution
that's more of a confession than a valid
political statement or argument and what
brian kilmeade
should be saying is you know it would be
really
stupid to go be violent and riot
in 50 states plus dc again given how
terribly
that went for the country last week and
given the fact that you'd be rioting
over the lies that trump has been
telling you which have no merit
50 or more court cases have found that
the lies that got you to riot
have no merit whatsoever so it's
we we've seen so much hypocrisy over the
last week and i know that hypocrisy
doesn't matter to the american right
anymore i know we
i've been here the last four years as
much as you have to the extent that
you've been here if there's any
three-year-olds in the audience then i
take it back
um we saw this with business regulation
over the last week for
40 years i even had a tweet that i
should have i should have pulled up here
for the last 40 years i wrote
it's been deregulate everything from
republicans
let businesses do whatever they want
don't enforce antitrust
get government out of business and the
people's lives
and then all of a sudden republicans on
january 8th
regulate social media monitor
big tech break up monopolies
create new laws to control business
tell businesses exactly what to do and
when they can ban someone and not ban
someone and blah blah blah
and now the we will never negotiate with
terrorist crowd is saying
i don't know guys aside from whether
impeachment is correct
it'll make trumpists be violent again so
you shouldn't do it no
trump is the one who should have thought
of that before
he incited a riot on the tail end of two
months of telling people lies that they
fell for about the election
that's where the responsibility is
period and if
brian kilmeade really wanted to do
something good for the country he would
say to his audience guys
whatever happens with impeachment
whatever happens with the 25th amendment
don't riot don't riot because you're
rioting over something that is
fake trump has lied to you you've been
tricked you've been bamboozled you've
been deceived
don't go and riot that's not something i
expect to hear brian kilmeade say
uh anytime soon you may not have known
this but when you see me
sitting here on the show i am often
wearing shirts by a company called teddy
stratford i asked them to be a sponsor
because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat-felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout